Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
You are looking at the queen
of breast‐feeding fashion.
You are one tough cookie.
This is your one shot
to get in the board room
of the biggest players on Earth.
If you open the door,
I'll walk in and sell it.
You are a force of nature.
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
You came here wanting
to live the American Dream.
‐That's exactly it.
‐I throw down.
‐Yay!
‐What is all this kumbaya crap?
Oh, no.
Reel it back in.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
I'm not afraid, Mr. Wonderful.
Bring it.
[ Gasp ] The horror!
Narrator: First into the tank
is a solution to an age‐old
problem in the kitchen.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Latangela Newsome.
I live in Allen, Texas.
‐Word.
And I'm seeking $75,000
in exchange for a 25% equity
in my company.
Now, I'm a woman
of many talents.
But one that I'm very noted for
is my home cooking,
and I throw down.
I'm also a single mom
to a growing boy,
and his all‐time favorite meal
are my deep‐fry chicken wings.
Mmm.
‐I love chicken wings.
The problem is, what do you do
with all that grease
when it's clean‐up time?
It's a pain in the butt.
Some of us just pour it
in an old coffee can,
which
should really be recycled.
Or even worse, some of us
just pour it down the drain.
[ Gasp ] The horror!
[ Laughter ]
Drain clogs due to grease
buildup are a costly nuisance.
Cities are wasting hundreds
of thousands of dollars
on pipeline replacements
due to fats, oils, and grease.
Environmental agencies
are screaming for responsible
grease disposal at home.
So, being the superwoman
that I am,
I set out
to find a new alternative.
Introducing Grease Bags.
[ Laughter ]
They are convenient,
disposable,
and even the packaging
is home compostable.
Just open it up, take your
grease, and it pour it in.
You watch your oil absorb
like magic.
So it'll never bother you again,
or clog up those pipes.
I am now the only person
with an eco‐friendly product
for at‐home grease disposal.
I am a monster‐preneur.
If you open up the door,
I walk in and sell it.
So, who's ready
to invest in me
so we can get cooking
with grease?
‐Can we see any samples?
‐Sure!
I have some handouts
for you guys.
Please.
Do you have
any of your chicken wings?
‐I do!
‐Yes!
I thought about it.
It never hurts to feed
a hungry Shark, now.
Here you go, Robert.
And Lori, I will let you grab
one of my prototypes as well.
Here you go, Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
Oh!
Wow, that is really good.
‐Do you like that chicken?
‐How good is this?
Well, thank you, Robert,
I appreciate that.
This is really good.
Latangela, what happened to that
grease when it went in the bag?
Well, we have a blend
of all‐natural
oil‐absorbing ingredients.
And so, what happens is
the pad inside that bag
is absorbing the oil.
Let me show you something.
Here is oil and water.
So, you can see the separation?
Yep.
Okay, so if I pour this
absorbent right over the top...
Is that the same material
that's in the bag?
Yes, it is.
It's encapsulating
and absorbing this oil.
When I pour this water
into this container here,
the water's gonna be clear.
You see that?
‐Oh, wow.
So yeah, you see
there's no oil in there.
Good for you.
‐Good for you.
‐So that way...
What's the absorbent
made of?
I can't tell you all my secrets,
Robert!
But it's basically all‐natural.
This stuff, I'll tell you ‐‐
this stuff right here
is used in oil spills.
So, it's safe for the plants,
it's safe for animals...
Smart.
... they use it
for bioremediation.
I guess what I'm really
asking...
Sure.
...is, there anything
proprietary
about the material
in the bag?
Yes,
I have a patent pending.
Not the material in the bag ‐‐
the combination
of the bag and the pad.
So, have you started selling
these yet, Latangela?
Not yet.
What I'm doing
is I found a manufacturer
and they are on the cusp
of this packaging.
‐I need to know the price.
‐Sure.
What we're planning on doing is
selling three at at a time.
People buy them, you know,
once a month.
And they'll be $12.99.
‐For three.
‐For three bags?
‐For three bags.
‐What does it cost you?
‐$2.34 for three bags.
So your margin is huge.
Well, right now
because we're in the beginning,
I don't know
what all of my costs will be.
And I sort of set it
so that we wouldn't run into
any issues right now.
That's smart.
‐This is a prototype?
‐Yes.
The bag itself is a prototype.
‐I will share something.
I have honestly
never fried anything.
‐Why?
‐I just ‐‐ I eat healthy.
I don't eat fried foods.
I have almost zero knowledge
about this.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐And, so for that reason,
I'm out.
Corcoran: Well,
I have a lot of knowledge
'cause I make bacon
every single morning.
When I have that bag
already half filled,
and I take my hot bacon grease,
can I pour it into that bag?
As of now,
it's not heat tempered.
Oh.
You need to let that grease cool
down just a little bit.
‐Huge problem.
‐Well, because that would be,
I think, a large use
that so many people
would have for that bag.
I'm afraid I'm out.
Can you fix that, Latangela?
To make it heat tempered?
Yes, I just wanna keep the bag
home compostable
so that it doesn't, um,
add waste to our landfills.
So that's your trade‐off ‐‐
making it compostable
versus heat tempered.
Right.
This, I think,
is a little flawed.
It's gonna leave too much
of a market unavailable.
It has to be a foil package.
Then it wouldn't be
compostable.
It would be able to take
the hot grease from bacon.
That's ‐‐
that's 50% bigger market.
Look, there's
an inherent conflict...
Mm‐hmm.
...in that the people
who are very green conscious
are gonna be your consumer.
Right.
Those typically are people
that are more health conscious,
and I don't think
are doing as much frying.
And so, I think that's gonna
create your biggest challenge.
And for those reasons,
unfortunately, I'm out.
‐I hate to hear that, Mark.
‐I know, I hate ‐‐ I always...
Because I really,
I really, really disagree.
I really think that people
are going to use this.
It's an oil‐absorbing product,
so even if you're changing
your oil at home on your car,
you can use it for that.
You can use it
for oil‐based paints.
I'm gonna give you an 8.62
for presentation skills.
‐How 'bout a 10 plus!
‐Thank you.
Oh, she gave you a 10!
The trouble with this product
is, I would never use it.
I cook bacon.
It's not gonna solve for me.
I'm out.
I hate to hear it,
Mr. Wonderful.
I disagree with Kevin.
I wouldn't give you an 8.6
out of 10.
I'd give you
a 10 out of 10.
Amazing presentation.
‐Thank you, I appreciate that.
This is a really tough one.
When we have this much doubt,
you know what I rely on?
Sales.
‐I understand.
I don't have that yet,
but I am so ‐‐
like I told you guys,
I'm a monster‐preneur.
In months I've gone
from filing a patent
to finding manufacturers
to finding all the supplies.
I have everybody in place.
Oh, no, there's not doubt ‐‐
you are a force of nature.
Oh, I have done it.
I've hit the road running,
Robert.
I'm telling you,
the environmental agencies ‐‐
they are really trying
to get people to understand...
Okay, Latangela, stop selling.
He's gotta make up his mind.
Latangela, too much unknown
with the product.
Believe in you, but...
I'm out.
Oh.
So, is that everybody?
By the way, best chicken
I've ever had, thank you.
Thank you.
I went out so fast earlier.
Let's pretend it didn't happen.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow.
Okay, awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
$12.99 for three bags
I think
is just way, way, way too much.
Could you sell this for $6.99
for three bags?
I think we can do that,
because it costs us ‐‐
each bag
is 78 cents to make.
Okay, I'll tell you what.
On that contingency that you
could cut the price in half,
I'll give you the money,
all right?
But I want 50%
of the business.
Barbara, I appreciate
that so much.
And I have to say...
...that I will take that deal.
‐Yes?
‐Yes!
‐Yay!
‐And you know,
in your spare time I'm gonna
have you sell real estate.
Oh, whatever you need me to do.
I'll walk in and sell it.
Cuban: Way to crush it,
Latangela. Congrats.
‐Thank you.
‐Wow.
‐Good job.
‐Goodbye, thank you.
‐Yo, wrong door.
‐Oh, sorry!
[ Laughter ]
I'm so excited!
I can't believe it!
[ Crying ]
She really believed in me.
And I love Barbara,
and I think she's gonna be
an awesome partner.
I'm so grateful.
I can't wait to tell my son!
♪♪
My name is Vlad, and I live
in Brooklyn, New York.
Originally,
I'm from Kiev, Ukraine.
I was a curious little child.
I would always wonder around
taking things apart,
sometimes not put them
back together.
The world was my playground.
Unfortunately,
my dad passed away
and we literally
lost everything.
My grandparents
immigrated to New York,
and my mom and I
followed soon after.
How is your business?
Going good.
I don't have an office
for my business.
I live in
a one‐bedroom apartment
with my grandparents
and my mom and the cat.
So a lot of times,
I just go to a local café,
and I work from there.
Kids are gonna love this.
Creativity was a really big part
of my childhood.
I really wanted to have
a product
that puts learning
to playtime.
Smolyanskyy:
That's you and dad!
Yeah.
We're in Paris together.
The hardest part
about coming to New York
was seeing my mom
adapt all by herself
with my dad not being around.
I felt like I needed to be
the man in the family
and support my mom
and make her happy.
And that's why I work so hard
to make this business a success.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name is Vlad,
and I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
I'm the founder and the creator
of Pinblock building blocks.
And I'm here seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 20% of my company.
Sharks! The future of our
children is in big trouble!
Millions of parents
are making one big mistake.
They value school
more than playtime.
You see, in school your children
are bogged by rules.
They memorize
and recite all day long.
But playtime at home
is when the self‐exploration
and the self‐development
actually takes place.
It is then your little Sharks
develop creativity,
decision‐making skills,
all the things that are really
important for their success.
Every day, more and more parents
realize this,
and give their children
the ultimate creative toy ‐‐
building blocks.
And that's
why I created Pinblock,
which requires no manual,
and every single piece
is exactly the same.
The long, round pins
on top of each block
allow your models to bend
and even fold.
Kevin, I said every single piece
is exactly the same,
so it allowed me to take
your beautiful face...
O'Leary: Yes.
... pixelate it,
and make a real‐life mural.
Extremely attractive.
So Sharks, I need your help
to unlock the creativity
of our children
and watch them build the future
one Pinblock at a time.
And now, guys, I've got
some personalized gifts.
How about I give them out?
Robert.
You're the protector
of the cyber space.
You'll be our warrior for today.
‐Ooh, I love it.
‐Don't forget your dagger.
‐Dagger?
Very cool!
Lori, Queen of QVC,
but you forgot your crown.
Thank you.
And a staff for you
to rule with.
Lots of present.
Kevin, I've brought some
Pinblock cash for you.
I like that, very cute.
Barbara, I got some really cool
accessories for you.
Oh, good.
I hope they're pure diamonds.
Let me help you out.
And a crown.
Cuban:
I get pizza? [ Laughs ]
I promise
the pizza's gluten‐free.
That's what Mark is known for ‐‐
eating.
‐What are your sales?
‐Yeah.
So, for sales we have 160K from
Amazon and from our website.
‐Can I see your box real quick?
‐Sure, certainly.
So, this is just
one of my different sets.
Thank you.
What does it cost, Vlad?
So, that one is
our start‐up pack ‐‐ $19.95.
How much does it cost you
to make?
It cost me $3.00.
With this starter pack,
what can I make?
That one in particular
actually comes with a manual,
but after that a kid
can go on our YouTube channel ‐‐
learn from my tutorials
that I make myself.
So, what about Toy Fair?
Have we been to Toy Fair?
‐Yes. January last year.
‐Yep.
So, over there we got
great responses.
We're just showing
the prototype. We're...
What happened with Walmart?
What happened with Costco?
What happened
with Toys "R" Us?
With the big‐box retailers,
they're generally not there
to seek out new products.
I sold them just one
from meeting to meeting.
And they loved it like,
"Yeah, this is really cool.
Send us a sample."
So you didn't get
any orders, then?
No. I took some orders
from smaller retailers, but...
Vlad, I'm dying to know
your background.
Where do you come from?
‐Originally, I'm from Ukraine.
And actually, my father ‐‐
he gave me a lot of inspiration.
He was into venture capital
and currencies.
Did he help fund
this business?
Unfortunately,
very early on he passed away.
Which kind of put me
in the position
where everything we had ‐‐
my mom and I had ‐‐
was taken away from us.
So, I ‐‐
it's crazy to think about it,
but since I was a little boy
I knew that I had a mission
to get it all back.
To kind of ‐‐ for my father,
to succeed him, you know?
To also become successful,
to continue his journey.
So by the time I started this
business, I was 18 years old.
So you came here wanting
to live the American Dream?
That's exactly it.
How old are you now,
if you don't mind my asking?
21, just turned.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Did you start this business?
Did you raise any money?
No, we didn't raise
any money.
I started this
with my best friend at the time,
and we together pulled our money
and we financed the prototype,
the production.
‐What happened to the friend?
Uh, my partner
was in the back end,
and I feel like he didn't feel
connected to the business.
So, does he still own
part of it?
‐He still owns 15%.
‐15?
15, one‐five.
So I own the rest ‐‐ 85.
‐And he's not there anymore?
‐No, he's not there.
Now Vlad, there are other blocks
I can create stuff like this.
‐I disagree.
‐Not bendable.
Actually, I would ask, "Would
you be able to make a crown?
Would you be able to make
a watch?"
‐And do you have a patent on it?
‐Yes, I applied for two patents,
and yesterday got
my design patent granted.
Good for you.
So, the design is
of the shape of the piece.
The design is exactly
how the piece looks.
That.
‐Yes, that.
‐That's useful.
O'Leary: I have to admit,
this is interesting
because it does a few things ‐‐
the bendability
plus the pixelation artwork
is kind of different.
You know, years ago
I sold my company to Mattel,
and I worked there
for a year and a half
and I got a pretty good dose
of the understanding
of the toy industry.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
The only way I see
for this to work
is that you actually partner
with another toy company
that's going to get this
into their product line.
They would probably license it
in perpetuity,
pay you a royalty.
I would do that deal,
but I want 30%.
In other words,
I'll give you the 100K
with a giant contingency.
I have no interest
in investing in this
unless I can put it into
a very large toy manufacturer
that provides marketing
and distribution globally.
This is actually something
that goes against
my original strategies.
My strategy is to really
build on the brand
where it's a necessity
for these big retailers
to carry my product,
because they have kids coming
into the front door and asking,
"Hey, where's Pinblocks?"
Vlad, everything
you just outlined,
you made it sound as
though as it's a very
easy thing to accomplish.
I'm sure you're aware it's gonna
take a heck of a lot of money.
I don't typically
like the deals he offers,
but with his experience,
I think that's a deal
you should consider.
So I'm out.
Greiner:
Vlad, in the toy space
it's very difficult
to make the consumer understand
a completely new product
like this.
It's a long road.
I'm out.
Herjavec: Vlad, look.
I always think great businesses
are built from great purpose.
I can just tell that's you.
I would try to license it,
but that's not your vision.
I wish you all the best.
But, I'm out.
Vlad, what you're doing
is incredible, right?
You're grinding through,
and there's a lot of
really amazing things
that you've accomplished.
But the toy business is brutal.
This isn't something for me.
I'm out.
‐I made you an offer.
‐Yes.
And the risk you have
when that occurs is,
you can see if there's another
one, or you can engage in mine.
And now,
you only have one option.
That gives me
a lot more leverage.
So, I'm gonna modify
my offer.
The only way this works is ‐‐
I'm gonna 50/50 partner
with you.
‐Oh!
‐Wow!
♪♪
Narrator: Vlad had one offer
on the table from Kevin
for 30% of his building toy,
Pinblock.
But with all the other Sharks
dropping out,
now Kevin
wants 50% of his company.
The only way this works is ‐‐
I'm gonna be a 50/50 partner
with you.
I'll give you $100,000
for 50% with contingency.
I'll bring it
to the toy industry,
because
they all return my call.
And I'll bring deals to you.
And if you want to turn them
down, that's fine.
But if you want to accept
one of them, we're 50/50.
You have no chance of doing
this successfully yourself.
So, your first offer was
for 30%...
And then you dropped out,
Robert.
Lori.
No Vlad, actually, that's
not as bad as you first think.
Which part of bad is not as bad
as you think, the 50%?
Because he gave Vlad ‐‐
no, he gave Vlad the option.
So you can set the bar
as high as you want
for that deal you like,
and then basically,
he's paying you to be
a sales rep and a partner,
a 50/50 partner.
One by one,
these Sharks dropped out
because they don't wanna
take on the task.
I happen to
come from this industry,
so I'm willing to give it
a shot.
But you're still in control.
This is your one shot
to get in the board room of
the biggest players on Earth.
Vlad, you should
take this offer.
This is a good deal for you.
‐[ Sighs ]
You know what,
stop telling him what to do.
I don't own the entire 100%.
I own 85.
So you, by taking 50%,
you're becoming the sole driver
of the company.
I want 50% of it.
How do you split up your 50%,
Vlad, is entirely up to you.
Vlad, do you think
you can do it alone?
This is
what it comes down to.
Do you feel like
you need that help?
♪♪
Kevin, let's do a deal.
‐Wow, shock!
‐Smart man.
‐Thanks, Vlad.
‐Smart man, Vlad.
‐Wow.
‐Congrats, Vlad.
I didn't think
that was gonna happen.
Congratulations.
Vlad, Vlad, the moral is ‐‐
Kevin thought he was making
a better deal, you won.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
Thank you, guys.
‐Take care, Vlad.
‐Congrats.
Kevin does take a big chunk
of my company.
I am the ‐‐ not the majority
stake holder anymore.
He is. Sucks.
But I do have a Shark on my
team, which is very valuable.
And I really am excited
to see where this takes us.
At the end of it all,
how many 21‐year‐olds can say
that they have Kevin O'Leary
as a partner?
♪♪
John:
My father's from Trinidad.
My mother
is African‐American,
but they got divorced
after my 10th birthday.
My mother had to start
working two and three jobs
to put the same food
on the table.
I grew up in Hollis, Queens.
My neighborhood
was a very peaceful place,
but then the crack epidemic hit.
It was very hard
avoiding that world.
A lot of my friends
became drug dealers.
A lot of my friends died.
I got left back in school
because I was kind of
hanging out in the streets,
but I had
a really good mother.
My mother never made me feel
like it was bad times,
even when we were going through
tough times.
She made me feel like
I was a special individual
and I was made
for something bigger.
Queens was a hotbed for hip‐hop.
The people that came
out of Queens were
LL Cool J, Tribe Called Quest,
Run‐D. M. C.,
and the list goes on and on.
People thought there was
something in the water.
They started to influence
everything you did ‐‐
the way that you dressed,
walked, talked.
It was just a world
that you had to be immersed in.
I like that.
Fashion was my expression,
and I saw a De La Soul video.
They were wearing a hat,
like a cut‐off sleeve,
with a tie on the top.
I went out and got some fabric,
and Mom showed me
how to sew a straight line,
and all of a sudden,
I had a whole bunch of hats.
Stand outside the Colosseum,
selling my bag of hats,
and I made $800 in one hour.
And that changed my life.
After that,
I started going to t‐shirts,
and I would go
to all the video sets I could.
And I would put it on a rapper
if they allowed me to.
All of a sudden, people started
to recognize the name FUBU ‐‐
For Us, By Us.
I want to be proud
of who was wearing my clothes,
and it was about a culture,
not a color.
And my friends would all jump in
when they weren't working.
We started to become known
as a huge clothing company
because all these videos
are playing,
but I was still working
as a waiter at Red Lobster.
We decide to go to a trade show
in Las Vegas,
and we write $300,000 of orders.
Now, all of a sudden,
I need financing.
I get turned down by 27 banks.
I come home to my mother
defeated, and she said,
"Then we're gonna have
to take a risk.
We're gonna take out
as much money as we can
out of this house.
You're gonna go
sell the clothes,
and then you're gonna
put the money back in the house,
'cause this
is all we have, son."
I have no idea why my mother
had so much faith in me
throughout my life.
I decide to turn my home
into a factory.
My mother moves out.
My friends move in.
We sleep in sleeping bags,
and we just keep selling
and selling and selling.
Within three years, I end up
signing a distribution deal.
We sell $400 million
and become a global brand.
These houses
have changed so much.
I'm a self‐proclaimed
mama's boy.
She's my rock.
She's my first mentor,
my first partner.
It's really
a good feeling to know
that maybe I gave her back
this much
of all she's given to me.
I would do it
all over again.
Well, hopefully
we don't have to.
Being an African American
with accomplishments
in this country
is extremely important to me.
Love you, brother.
How you doing?
The role that I play
is to show the world
that drive
doesn't have a color.
We've got a Shark here
named Daymond John.
John:
Being a Presidential Ambassador
for Global Entrepreneurship
has been a very humbling
experience and enlightening.
I always say that
I am just a little brown boy
from Queens that made it
to this point in my life,
and I want all
the little brown boys, girls,
white, black, doesn't matter,
to know if you apply yourself,
you can be whoever you want.
Thank you, Ma.
I love you so much.
I love you, too.
Mwah!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur with a
mission to support nursing moms.
[ Sneezes ]
Bless you.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name's Elena Petzold and I'm
from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
Whoo‐hoo! [ Laughs ]
‐[ Laughs ]
I am the creator
of Mama's MilkBox,
and today I'm seeking $200,000
for 20% of my company.
Sharks, take a look at my
beautiful ladies right here.
Don't they look amazing?
Aren't their outfits
spectacular?
And guess what else.
They are breast‐feeding moms
who are able nurse their baby
on demand
or pump at a moment's notice.
Mama's MilkBox delivers
breast‐feeding style
right to the door.
We're a nursing apparel
subscription service,
and for only $29 a box.
First, our subscribers
complete a style profile.
Based on that profile,
our breast‐feeding stylists
hand‐select nursing tops
and dresses to match.
We then send that
curated shipment to their house,
where they have three days
to try on the clothes
in the comfort and privacy
of their own home.
After three days,
they keep what they want,
and then they mail back
the rest.
We take that $29 styling fee
and we apply it as a credit
to any of their keeps,
and then we automatically
schedule their next shipment
for delivery in six weeks.
In the breast‐feeding world,
we call breast milk liquid gold.
Who wants to get in on the
liquid gold rush with me?
[ Laughter ]
The breast‐feeding world.
[ Laughing ] Right?
You are looking at the queen
of breast‐feeding fashion.
What I did
for your sample shipments
is I tried to envision
your style profile.
Lori, I know you love a play on,
like, structure.
Barbara, you're normally
bright‐colored,
so there's a couple
of bright pieces in there.
I think this would look good
on me.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I don't judge. Go for it.
So, if I heard you correctly,
you charge me $29 a month,
but that's
just the curating fee.
Yes.
So in your example,
is this box arrives
and I say,
"Wow, I want to buy this."
I then have to purchase it.
‐You just keep it...
‐Right.
‐... and then send back
whatever in that box
you don't you want.
So I send these back ‐‐
How do I pay you for this one?
We automatically bill you.
And then, you get a 10% discount
if you keep it all.
So, all you're doing is
you're a fashion stylist
and you're curating
other people's brands.
No, we have
our own private label.
So in this box
that you sent me...
This is my own private label.
Oh, I was nervous
when you did that!
‐I know, so was I!
‐Look, I get that.
How many are yours in here,
typically?
Well, I want to have
a higher proportion
of our private label in the box.
‐How many are today?
‐At least one or two pieces.
What's your margin on
the products that you
resell from others?
It's usually around the 50%,
but is hard to tell.
I really need better technology.
Like, that is why I'm here.
So you need
a financial person.
That is why I'm asking...
I don't even need finance.
I could go to a bank.
I need a partner...
You're doing this yourself?
No, you need somebody
that's gonna do your P&L's,
that's gonna be,
like, helping you.
Because
if you don't know here,
like, what's the profit
that your making...
Oh, yeah, no.
I need better...
‐Because, is it just you?
‐Yeah.
Is it just you packing
the boxes, shipping them out?
‐I hired somebody in March.
‐Yeah.
And then I hired somebody
two weeks ago to also assist,
and now we're...
Just walk me through the
inventory for a second, okay?
So there's three of you
running the business.
Because, here's what I think
is happening.
I got a business
called Surprise Ride
that ships boxes to people
every month,
and it's
a subscription service.
Every month
they're different.
Every month they curate
to every single mother.
But they also pick select
products...
Hang on.
‐This is not custom.
‐But tell me what's different.
‐I listen to what the mom's say.
‐Well, hear me out.
They want to diminish the
appearance of the large breasts.
‐Elena, I get all that.
‐They go for those clothes.
I wanna talk about
the inventory challenge.
Do you pick and pack,
you put them in the box...
First of all, our model
is more amazing
than a traditional retail model.
‐But let me ask you if...
‐Well, let him ask the question.
‐Actually, you have challenges.
‐Let me finish.
Well, of course we have
a lot of challenges.
As more and more people
come into the platform,
now every week or every cycle
that you're sending them a box,
you have to buy the inventory,
you have to put it
on your shelf,
that ties up capital.
Then you put it in the box
that hasn't been paid for yet.
You go...
I've already negotiated
a bunch of net terms,
and I'm also crazy at driving
down the wholesale prices.
But tell me where I'm...
You've got an answer
for everything.
I'm not afraid, Mr. Wonderful.
Bring it.
Give me the tough questions.
‐Wow.
I'm gonna tell you where
you're gonna hit a brick wall
in a minute, okay?
‐[ Laughs ]
Because
what's gonna happen to you
is you're actually going to go
out of business.
And I'll tell you why.
This is a calculation called
"return on assets," okay?
This is a really important part
of your model.
As you grow and you keep sending
boxes to people,
you have to have inventory
on the shelf.
That's cash.
You have to buy it with cash.
What you need to do
is to quicken the cycle
from when you have to
buy the inventory
to curate the fashion
to ship it to somebody...
The moms can select if they want
to receive it sooner,
but that's actually how
I've been able to get
this to this level.
‐No, but.
‐I do like keeping it at the...
If you're
really successful...
I have customers lined up,
and I know when...
‐You're not listening to me.
‐What level are you at?
Corcoran: Can I ask you
to slow down on your answers?
It seems like
everything we ask,
before we even get the words out
you're jumping right in it.
And it's going to work
against you.
So just take a breath.
It's important to have
enthusiasm, but take a breath.
Love the enthusiasm.
What are you sales?
What are your sales
of your great store?
Last year, $83,000 in sales.
And that was actually
on the side,
because I was busy
raising my children.
We've already surpassed last
year's sales at about $84,000.
By the time I close out
this month,
we'll be at $100,000,
because I have about 100
shipments I have to process
when I get back.
And how much do you have
in inventory?
In cash?
About $160,000.
‐$160,000?
‐$160,000 in inventory?
When you ask
how much is in it,
are you asking the wholesale
or the retail?
‐What's your costs...
‐Your wholesale costs.
Your wholesale.
How much did you pay
for your inventory?
Um...
This is a big,
important number, Elena.
I understand.
It's about $120,000.
Okay, Elena, Elena,
where did you get $120,000
to support that inventory?
I started the business
with $11,000
and I have never taken a salary
on it,
so I keep turning it over.
Then I bought more clothes, and
I turned that into more profit.
But you've also put
your own money in.
But your margin's...
I did a line of credit
for $40,000.
There you go.
Okay.
‐I'm not fancy.
‐So, do you have that?
‐I'm smart, but I'm not fancy.
‐Is that on ‐‐
is that debt now, the $40,000?
‐Yeah.
$40,000 line of credit,
and then I've got $27,000
on credit cards.
You sold $100,000.
What did it cost you?
What are the cost of goods ‐‐
to get that $100,000 to sell,
what did it cost you?
I can't tell you that.
So, how do you keep track
of everything?
How do you do your books?
‐Excel and paper.
‐Elena, we've all been...
‐That's why I'm here!
‐No, but Elena...
You guys, if I can make $100,000
using Excel and paper...
‐Elena, you know...
‐You didn't make $100,000.
An Excel spreadsheet's okay.
[ Laughs ]
You haven't made anything
yet.
Don't confuse
selling $100,000
with making $100,000.
Profit, is that what you mean ‐‐
what you're saying?
Yeah,
because like Kevin said,
you keep on adding to your debt,
right, to finance all this.
That could
all be lost money,
and your falling
further and further behind.
You've sold $100,000 here.
You've got $120,000
in inventory.
Yes.
And you've got $67,000
in debt,
and it never occurred to you
to say,
"We need an accountant
or bookkeeper
to make sure I know
what's going on."
Well, I have an accountant
and he's my husband,
and he's very good.
The problem is, he's not
dedicated to this business.
He has his own job.
Well, then, that's still
the same answer, Elena.
You didn't get it done.
I'm out.
Oh, no. Okay.
Reel it back in.
'Cause I am here ‐‐
no, I am really here for a deal.
Like, I know this business
is gonna make money.
I am the queen
of breast‐feeding fashion.
You don't know, though.
There is no ‐‐ there is no other
clothes in the United States
and the plans for this business.
‐You don't know.
The mistake ‐‐ the mistake
in your presentation...
I gotta develop
the private label.
Like I said, I'm not fancy,
so maybe I don't know
these, like, crazy numbers
that I'm supposed to know
a little faster
off the top of my head.
But that's ‐‐
I can learn that, too.
I am not afraid.
I mean,
if I don't understand something
I go in there
and I'm like, "Look..."
Corcoran: You know what...
I actually think ‐‐
I actually think
it's very hard for me to
see if you really have
a good business here.
It's just that
it's so very confusing
that you don't enable us
to make a decision,
"Yes, we want that thing."
‐I‐‐
So, because of the confusion,
I'm out.
‐Thank you for your feedback.
‐A pleasure.
I mean, I really do ‐‐
this business, I'm expecting,
is gonna be up to $220,000
by the end of the year.
Mr. Wonderful, the fact that
you keep looking at numbers,
let me explain it to you, too ‐‐
and Lori, also, and Robert.
If you guys want to be
dead to me, that's fine.
I want you to come back.
I will hope to try
and bring you back.
I know every single thing
there is to know
about breast‐feeding clothes.
And from all around the world.
‐Elena, you can stop selling.
But I don't wanna buy
from them.
Everybody understands
what you're doing.
You can't own this inventory
and acquire customers
and own it while it
moves all around the country.
And you are losing money...
‐You know what?
you are gonna give up on women,
'cause the fact of the matter
is there is not gonna be
breast‐feeding clothes.
It has nothing to do
with giving up on women.
with...
Like, these designers
are not selling it
at their retail level.
It has nothing to do
with the women.
I love what you're doing.
The model is broken.
It doesn't work.
I'm out.
Thank you for your feedback.
Elena, why is the
moms and the breast‐feeding ‐‐
why is this
such a passion for you?
I mean, 'cause I am a mom.
[ Laughs ]
Because I breast‐fed
two kids,
and I know what it feels like
to not feel good.
Elena, I admire the cause
and people are very passionate
about it.
Nobody doubts your enthusiasm.
It's off the charts.
It's infectious,
I know, thank you.
‐It's...
‐I am a character.
But look, you're...
People like talking to me,
I get it.
But see, you're not even
listening to me.
No, I'm listening to you,
it's off the charts, I'm sorry.
You're not, you're not,
and that's the problem.
If you wanna have a cause,
go for it.
If you want to run a business,
at a certain point,
you can't deflect.
This is the "Shark Tank."
We love our businesses
as much as you love your cause.
And for the business that you
pitched, it doesn't add up.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Lori, give me a life line here.
[ Laughs ]
I'm like, if you're not in here
how can I ‐‐ can I get you?
I am definitely disappointed
in myself for this moment,
'cause I feel like I've done
a not‐good representation then,
if this is the feedback.
Listen, passion is great,
but it's only a fraction
of running a business.
I also think that
the subscription model here
is gonna be
really challenging.
I don't think the model's
going to work for you.
I think you need
a lot of help.
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Good luck, Elena.
Oh, I had my moment
and it sucked, but thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, gosh.
‐Wow.
‐That was unbelievable.
I didn't wanna do the ugly cry,
but I need a tissue.
Does anybody have a tissue?
No, you guys lead me here
with no tissue? [ Chuckles ]
You know what,
she wasn't here for a deal.
She was here
for a life preserver.
Oh, my God.
She would kill me.
All right, now I need a drink.
I need like, a stiff drink.
I need a drink.
Painful to watch that.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is an accessory company
inspired by yoga.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Lisa Binderow.
I'm the CEO and founder
of Nicepipes Apparel.
And I'm asking for $100,000
for 10% of my business ‐‐
the hottest new thing
on the active wear market.
But first, let me give you
the origin story.
So, I'm a yoga teacher.
I'm walking home
from teaching my class,
and I'm freezing cold
in my crop pants, right?
And all I can find are these
sweater‐material leg warmers.
They're itchy,
they don't stay up,
and they don't keep you
that warm.
Ugh, terrible!
So that weekend,
I designed
leg warmers and arm warmers
made from the same
amazing fabric as yoga pants.
Nicepipes are unique.
They add style, color,
and functionality
affordably
to every workout wardrobe.
So Sharks, who's ready
to show me their pipes?
[ Laughs ]
So, I have some back here,
in what looks
like an appetizer tray.
‐Thank you.
‐I have pink for Lori.
‐Oh, I like that.
‐Camo for Kevin.
‐Do you make them in America?
I make them in L. A.,
actually.
‐What does this sell for, Lisa?
‐For $42.
Corcoran and Herjavec: What
does it cost you to make them?
Thank you, Robert.
So, when I started they were
$10, but they're now $7.50.
How do you sell them?
I sell them on my website,
and we're in 40 stores.
Mostly yoga studios,
gyms, places like that.
What are your sales, Lisa?
My first season, I was selling
out of my apartment.
And when did you start, when you
say your first season was...
It was last winter,
so about 18 months ago.
I did about a little over
$80,000 in sales.
Love everything about it.
How's the business
worth $1 million today?
Yeah, 10 times lifetime sales
is a lot.
Yeah, like you seem
so reasonable and normal...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐... until I look at the value.
So, I think
there's major potential,
and the reason that I know that
is because I am a customer.
It's my world.
I've been in the fitness
industry for eight years.
Every time I teach a class,
everyone wants to buy it.
Here's why
it's not worth a million.
While it's
a very creative product,
it's not proprietary
whatsoever.
Anybody can knock you off.
The amount of stores your in
is tiny
compared to the amount of stores
it could be in.
It's sort of like a hobby,
in a way.
A hobby ‐‐ how insulting.
Tell him he can take a walk.
O'Leary: No, because you ‐‐
if you went downstairs
and got run over
by a truck...
[ Laughs ]
These are my options?
[ Laughter ]
‐I'm just saying...
‐This is how Kevin negotiates.
‐I ‐‐ listen.
‐There's no infrastructure.
There's no ‐‐ you're...
If someone had said
to Sara Blakely,
like, "Don't make Spanx...
Don't make
control‐top pantyhose
because Hanes
is gonna beat you up..."
I absolutely agree,
and I know her.
You gotta understand, looking...
‐And she listened to that,
like, she is Spanx,
I am Nicepipes.
Look at the growth
of her business.
She has thousands of employees.
‐Good answer.
But she didn't
when she started.
The point is that everybody
starts with one thing.
‐You're right.
‐Everybody starts somewhere.
So what's your point?
Why are only valued
at a million?
Why isn't it $100 million?
Oh, my, sorry, I remember ‐‐
she had sales!
Oh, never mind.
‐[ Laughs ]
How much money did you put
into the business?
So, I've put in
just shy of $300,000.
‐Whoa!
‐$300,000?
‐$300,000!
‐Wow!
Why did you ‐‐
how did you spend so much money?
Where did it go?
I'm sitting on $65,000 worth
of inventory right now.
So, what's
your core competency?
What is it
that you're just phenomenal at?
I think that I am
a valuable executive.
I think
that I understand people.
I think I understand
how to manage people.
I think I understand the...
‐You're killing me, Lisa.
What's wrong with that,
Mark?
Because that's so generic,
right?
It's not generic at all.
You gotta have something you
fall back on where you say,
"I am so good at this,
no one can touch me."
‐She's a great executive.
‐Look at me.
I'm standing here, doing this.
And I feel like I'm doing great.
Listen, if you don't agree with
him, give him hell, Harry.
All men think
they're right all the time.
I think I executed
this exceptionally well
with no background in business.
‐That's fine.
Do you think companies
don't need CEOs?
‐You're not a CEO.
‐Yeah, it's you.
You're an entrepreneur,
and that's great.
But you're not a CEO.
When you stand on that carpet
and you tell me your business
is worth $1 million,
all the niceties and all
the stuff goes out the window.
The fact that
you had to spend $300,000...
That's her choice, Mark.
What she chose to spend her
money on is her choice.
The fact
that she had to spend that much,
because you didn't know
what you were confident in.
It's not that I don't know
what I'm confident in.
It's that I have determination,
and I think that
is more valuable than saying,
"I'm really good
at designing."
Was $300,000
your entire life savings?
Listen, let's just say we're not
buying a house any time soon.
At the end of the day, this is
a business that did $80,000.
There is no scenario
on this planet
where this is worth
$1 million.
I'm out.
Okay.
Lisa, I never wanna rain
on anybody's parade.
I love the fact
you started a business.
You lose all credibility
when you stand there
and you tell me you think
this is worth $1 million.
It doesn't make me trust you.
It's so incomprehensible.
I hate hearing that you don't
trust me. That's...
Well, I just don't know
how you make a valid decision
to say
it's worth $1 million.
I just don't get there.
I can't take it seriously.
I'm out.
‐Okay.
Get out there and just sell,
right?
Yeah.
'Cause you got
all that inventory.
Every waking moment that
you're not doing something else,
while you're thinking
of ideas,
be out there selling
and taking orders.
Because you should be able to
kill it with this product.
You just have to
get that focus on sales.
It's not a fit for me.
I'm out.
Listen, I don't think
that you can always know
exactly
what you're gonna be great at
when you first start
a business.
You have to figure that all out
for yourself.
I did it. I had no help.
I had no mentor.
You can do it.
I like the product.
‐Yeah.
But, I see it
as a nice business for you.
I'm out.
‐Thank you, Lori.
Why do you think the business
is worth $1 million?
Um...
I'm just gonna like,
be brutally honest...
Brutally honest
is always good.
... and I mean, at this point
I might as well
just lay it out there, right?
Yeah.
I didn't know
how to value a business.
‐Did you come in to negotiate?
‐Absolutely.
I didn't want to come in and
ask for a number that was lower,
and then have no room.
Well, I would label that
common sense,
not a bad trait
to have in business.
What I like best about you
is that not many entrepreneurs
that stand up here and when Mark
is throwing a ton at them,
when Mr. Wonderful, who we all
know is not wonderful at all,
throwing a lot of crap
at the entrepreneur,
and you just kept talking
right through their talk.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐You don't see that often.
‐Have we seen that often?
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐You're one tough cookie.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
‐So, here's my offer.
I need to take 40%
of your business for $100,000.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Barbara is interested
in Lisa's arm and leg warmer
company, Nicepipes,
but she wants
40% of her business.
And there's one huge
contingency.
It's contingent
on Grace and Lace
agreeing to partner with me
on this deal.
Grace and Lace
is a great leggings company
that I invested on "Shark Tank"
that does $20 million a year.
‐Wow, that's amazing.
‐Just think about that.
Here's what they could do
for you.
They don't spend a dime,
and all of their sales
come through social media.
So you'd be getting a partner
that you really need.
But I want them in with me
before I would give you
that money.
What do you want to do?
I want to think for a second.
Don't think too long.
I think being able to work with
someone like Grace and Lace
is like a dream come true
for me.
‐Very valuable.
‐Um...
hmm.
Well, get focused here,
Lisa.
But I think that 100...
You say you're a great CEO.
Make your decision.
I wanna come back
with $100,000 for 25%.
Not doable.
Okay.
I appreciate that offer
so much,
but I don't think that
I'm willing to give away 40%.
Maybe I'm not doing it the right
way in the first 18 months,
but I have faith in myself
that I will figure it out.
Don't you dare
second‐guess yourself.
I do have faith in myself
that I will figure it out.
Lisa, are you sure?
You have
a non‐proprietary sock
and you're sitting alone
in your living room.
Come on,
it doesn't make sense.
This thing,
anybody can knock off.
Be honest with yourself.
You know what?
I'm honest with myself,
but I also believe in myself.
Lisa, you don't have to
explain it to Kevin.
You stick to your guns.
‐My goodness, what a mistake.
Greiner: You know what?
Lisa, stick to your guns.
Stick to your guns
and show us all
that you made
the right move.
Lisa, the best revenge
is success, right?
Yeah.
So, you said no.
‐Thank you. Good luck.
‐Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
‐Go out and prove me wrong.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
It would've been great
to get a deal,
but I just did not want
to give away 40% of my business.
That's not why I started it.
And who knows
what will happen next?
But I know that I just did the
best that I could do out there.
[ Crying ] I know I did,
and I'm proud of myself.
She's gonna ‐‐
she's gonna grind it...
‐I'm having second thoughts.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐The fact that she made...
‐Figure that out!
The fact that she made
that decision
shows you missed a bullet.
She doesn't know
what she's doing wrong.
No, no.
The fact
that she made that decision
proves
that she's terrific.
♪♪